الواقع بتعود ل 2016 مثل ما قلنا لورا
اللي كانت عشرين سنه وقتها قالت انها
قابلت سعد في نايت كلوب ورجعت معه الفندق
اللي كان فخم في الشانزليزيه وانه كان تحت
او كانت هي تحت تاثير الكحول والكوكايين
وانهم شربوا سوا ورقصوا وبعدين حاول يعتدي
عليها وضررها عده مرات لما قاومته
واغتصبها في النهايه وان بعدها غادرت
الغرفه وشافها موظفين الاوتيل بتبكي
وتتالم امام المحكمه امس سعد انكر التهم
وقال انه يمكن احترام كبير للنساء وانه
بيستفيد من شهرته لنقل كل ما هو ايجابي
للناس باحترام وقال انه عانى السنوات
الماضيه توتر كبير واكتئاب بسبب الروايه
هذه وانه انتظر سبع سنوات عشان يتكلم عن
القصه هذه اللي سببت له ولاهله الضرر
ومصادر كمان قالت انه قال امام القاضي انه
كان وقتها بيشرب الكحول وبيتعاطى المخدرات
وبين حين واخر وانه الان توقف عن ذلك
لورا الضحيه نقلت انباء انها اجهشت
بالبكاء اول ما شافت سعد في المحكمه وانها
دارت وجهها لما وقف عرف عن نفسه وتكلم
امام القاضي اما زوجه سعد فكمان تكلمت
امام المحكمه وقالت انه ساعات تقدم خطبها
وهو في السجن الاحتياطي وانه محبه حنون
وانه تعرفه من سنوات ولا يمكن للشخص اللي
تعرفه يكون عمل ما هو متهم به وقالت انه
بيحترم النساء وانه احيانا كان بيتعاطى
المخدرات وانها بتعلم انه بريء ومصديقته
ومقتنعه بكلامه سعد المجرد امام المحكمه
رفض الحديث عن قضيه اغتصاب اخرى متهم فيها
في امريكا ولمن سال ليه غادر امريكا قال
كان عندي مشكله وكان لازم اغادر ولمن سال
ايش هي المشكله قال ما ابغى اتكلم في
الموضوع سعد كان اسمه برز في قضيه اغتصاب
في امريكا في 2010 وبحسب وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه فان الملاحقات ضده اسقطت بعد
تسويه مع الضحيه لم يعلن عن قيمتها وفي
2017 وجهت لو تهمه الاغتصاب من فتاه
فرنسيه مغربيه قالت انها تعرضت للاعتداء
الجنسي والضرب على يد المغني في الدار
البيضاء عام 2015 وفي 2018 وفي فرنسا في
بنت ثانيه غير لورا اتهمته باغتصابها في
مدينه
ووقتها انحبس احتياطي لاشهر واطلق سراحه
بعدها لكنه اجبر على وضع اسواره الكترونيه
لتتبع تحركاتو وفي كلام عن اتهامات اخرى
كمان
طيب معنى من طنجه الصحفيه المتابعه للقضيه
حنان عبد الله اهلا فيك معنا حنان حنان
نحن تابعنا هذه القضيه مع بعض من البدايه
من لمن اول مره تم فيها اعتقال سعد المجرد
بعد ما اتهمته الفتاه اول شيء ليش الموضوع
اخذ سبع سنين ليوصل للمحكمه خصوصا انه في
كثير ناس اعتقدوا انه مشاكل سعد تماما
انتهت بما انه بيسافر وبيروح وبيجي يعني
اهلا وسهلا اولا ساره كما قلت يعني تابعنا
هذا الملف مع بعض منذ البدايه وتاخر
القضاء الفرنسي او المحكمه الجنائيه مثلا
الفرنسيه في اعطائها الكلمه الاخيره في
هذا الملف لا تعني بان قضاء او قضيه سعد
المجرد قد انتهت ولا تعني بانه سيعود الى
حياته اليوميه ما يجب على المتلقي ان
يعرفه عن فرنسا من ناحيه القضاء في هذا
الاطار هو انه للاسف في فرنسا المسطره
القضائيه في اطار
يعني العنف والاغتصاب معقده جدا ملفات
عديده لمشاهير
واشخاص في هذا الاطار ما زال تاخذ مجراها
منذ عشر سنوات وعشرين سنه تاخرت كثيرا
لماذا لانه المحاكم في فرنسا عندها يعني
امور معينه تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار وتحقيقات
تاخذ مجرى طويل جدا
والضحايا او الضحيه لا يمثل امام القضاء
الا مره واحده في السنه وبهذا مره واحده
في السنه اذا اردت ان تبث في ملف كملف
اعتداء
لفات من هذا النوع تاخذ سنوات طويله جدا
وحتى اللحظه لسنا متاكدين من ان سعد
المجرد سيخرج منها هذه السنه بل ما زال
الامر مستمر طيب وهو في خلال الفتره
الماضيه كان حاصل على اذن من المحكمه
بالسفر
والتحرك يعني طيب ايش نعرف عن اللي دار
داخل المحكمه لانه في تفاصيل كثير تم
تداولها على الانترنت
ما نعرفه وما هو حقيقه هو ان الضحيه
طالبت بمواجهه سعد المجرد وتطالب بان تكون
المحاكمه امام العلن ارادت ان تكون هناك
مواجهه بينها وبينه لانها تقول على فكره
في هذا الاطار اقوال لغه لم تتغير نهائيا
بل ما يحدث في الملف هو انه سعد المجرد
هناك تدبدبات في كلامه يعني في الاول لم
يتحدث
والمحامين اللي كانوا معاه منذ البدايه
نافو نسب اليه هو اليوم يقول امام القضاء
بانه يحترم النساء وبانه كذا وكذا ولكن
هذه الامور تدخل في اطار ربما استغلال
الملف عاطفيا حتى يتم البث نهائيا في هذا
الامر يجب تذكير بان لغه خيول تطالب بان
ياخذ القضاء مجراه ورفضت ما عرض عليها
يعني عرض عليها شك بمبلغ كبير جدا ورفضته
هل صحيح
فعلا فعلا هذا المبلغ يعني هو الذي عرض
على لغه انا تحدثت
نحن بنقول من طرف
بم
عنى اوكي عرض عليها هذا المبلغ ضخم حتى
تتخلى عن القضيه ولكنها لا تريد لانه ما
حدث هي انها بعد ان بعد ان وقع ما وقع
واتهمت سعد المجرد بالاعتداء الجنسي
والاغتصاب وتواصلت معها نساء من المغرب
وخارج المغرب قالوا بانهن تعرضوا للاعتداء
الجنسي من طرف سعد المجرد ما جعل لغه
تطالب بحقها وحق هؤلاء النساء اللواتي لا
يستطيعن ان يتحدثن في العالم العربي عن ما
حدث لهن من طرف سعد المجرد هذول النساء هل
هم طرف في هذه القضيه هل تم استدعائهم
للشهاده مثلا
هناك شهاده من طرف اخذت بعين الاعتبار
لشابه مغربيه يعني لم تظهر المحكمه ولا
حتى ما يحدث وتحقيقات لا اسمها ولكن نعلم
بانها مغربيه هناك قضيه اخرى لفتاه
بلجيكيه تم تسويتها ايضا
بالمال ولكن الفتاه البلجيكيه وين تم
تسويه القضيه من الراقصات التي كانت مع
سعد المجرد في في حفل بتونس وحدث ايضا شيء
من هذا النوع بينهما ولكن تم تسويه الامر
بين هذا غير الامريكي القضيه اللي في
امريكا
والامريكيه تم تسويتها بالمال ايضا ايضا
وتم الاعلان عن هذا الموضوع قبل سنتين
تقريبا الان
على فكره يعني هناك خصوصيه في هذا الموضوع
لانه سعد المجرد كان حاضر رفقه اصدقاء له
من الخليج كان معزوم عندهم في الجنوب
الفرنسي ما وقع هو انه كان ممنوع عليه
اتذكر بانه المحامي اللي كان عنده الملف
منع عليه ان يخرج من باريس سعد المجرد ذهب
الى سنتربى تناول للاسف مخدرات خرج عن
السيطره ما جعله يرتكب بعض الحماقات التي
تمكن الاصدقاء من لمها وجمعها لكن جرائم
ليست لا تعتبر حد الجريمه ولكنها تقريبا
بالنسبه على فكره تعامل المراه الفرنسيه
مع تصرفات الرجل مختلف تماما عما نقوم به
في العالم العربي بمعنى انه اذا قمت بلمس
الاوروبيه او الفرنسيه وهي لم تعطيك حق
انت المسها فهذا بالنسبه لها اعتداء عالمي
هذا عالمي الموضوع عربي
عالمي المفروض يكون هذا ما
في فرق صراحه في هذا الموضوع طيب المتوقع
الان القضيه مستمره اذا يعني بعد سلسله
القضايا هذه عنده هذه القضيه القضيه
مستمره ايش المتوقع في موضوع الاحكام
موضوع الاحكام هو ان غرفه التحقيق بمحكمه
الاستئناف اعاده الملف للقضاء بمعنى
المحكمه الجنائيه الفرنسيه علما ان غرفه
تحقيقات اثبتت وقالت بانه هناك اعتداء
جنسي وهناك يعني ما تطالب به ومقالته
الضحيه حقيقي القضاء او المحكمه الجنائيه
الفرنسيه اليوم ستاخذ مجراها في هذا
الاطار بالرغم من انه يعني
محكمه النقض يعني ارجعت الملف وقالت بانه
ليست هناك جنسيه الغرفه التحقيق اثبت ذلك
الان المحكمه الجنائيه يجب ان تجد
نقطه حوار بين الاثنين لانه
رافضه تماما لاي تسويه بالمال وتريد ان
تتخذ محكمه الفرنسيه مجراها يقال او مقاله
المحامي هو ان سبعه سبع سنوات مرت منذ ان
انطلق هذا الملف هذا معناه بانه سيخفف
الحكم على سعد المجرد وهذا لن يمنع سعد
المجرد من يعني الحكم عليه بتقريبا عشر
سنوات سجنا هنا في او في فرنسا بس قد يحصل
على البراءه ايضا
ذكرنا في بدايه قضيه سعد المجرد خلال
تحقيقات الاوليه بان هناك اعتداء هناك
اعتداء على الضحيه
اذا طيب
ثبت الاعتداء الجنسي هناك شهود من الفندق
شاهدوا مع الضحيه بانها كانت نعم نعم نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله وهذه
المعلومات واكيد طبعا حنتابع هذه القضيه
وبالطبع بس بنذكر انه الفنان سعد لمجرد في
اي وقت حابب يعمل مداخله يوضح فيها اي امر
او يناقض اي امر او او هو مرحب في في اي
وقت له حق الرد كانت معنا من طنجه الصحفيه
المتابعه للقضيه حنان عبد الله شكرا لك
[موسيقى]